. Hey, hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge von DPU, das Podcast so fuhr mit mir, Stefan Tietze und dir, Florentin Will. Jetzt weiß ich, woher ich dich kenne, Stefan Tietze, Mensch, mir lag es die ganze Zeit auf der Zunge. Wir haben uns so lange nicht gesehen. Stimmt, zwei Wochen nicht gesehen. Wir haben uns schon fast vergessen, du bist ein anderer Mensch, du hast wahnsinnig viel erlebt in diesen zwei Wochen. Naja. Ich glaube, ich werde mich hier einfach zurücklehnen und einfach deinen tollen Erzählungen lauschen. Du warst in Cannes, du warst in Chicago, du bist geflogen, du hast eigentlich alles erlebt, also du hast wirklich das Leben in vollen Zügen genossen. Können wir das nächste Woche besprechen. Ich bin heute, also du siehst, ich bin mit dem Kofferrad reingeschneit. Ja, ja, ja. Ich bin heute Morgen aus Chicago geflogen und seitdem habe ich nicht geschlafen, also ich bin jetzt seit 24 Stunden auf den Beinen. Das ist ein großer Tag, der gerade verschwimmt und es es ist immer ganz spannend, was das für Tageszeiten auch sind, die einem das Flugzeug mit auf den Weg gibt. Weil das verstehe ich immer nicht so ganz. Das hatten wir auch schon mal das Thema. Aber das ist mir so wichtig, das nochmal ansprechen würde gerne. Weil aus Chicago zurück macht man immer Nachtflüge. Also aus Amerika zurück sind immer Nachtflüge. Dann geht man abends, steckt man ein, so gegen 16 Uhr ungefähr, also früher Abend, Nachmittag Richtung Abend und dann hast du quasi eine schnelle Nacht. Du fliegst dann quasi in die Nacht rein. Unter und wieder auf. Ja. Wie so ein Dip, die dippt einmal so in den Horizont, sieb wieder da. Es ist wie so ein Teebeutel, der den liebe Gott von oben kurz reindippt.
Und dann ist das Flugzeug. Wie so ein Dip, die dippt einmal so in den Horizont, ist wieder da. Es ist wie so ein Teebeutel, der liebe Gott von oben kurz reindippt.
Und dann ist, und das Flugzeug
simuliert aber eine längere Nacht.
Und wenn du hinfliegst,
fliegst du ja quasi in dem
besonnenen Teil der Sonne mit
und trotzdem erzählt das Flugzeug,
gibt es diese Lichtstimmung
und das Flugzeug erzählt quasi eine Dämmerung.
Dann wird plötzlich, werden diese blauen Lichter rot, dann geht es aus, dann wird man gezwungen, auch unter anderem physischer Gewalt, die Lenden runterzumachen und die Augen zuzumachen. Und dann wird es wieder erzählt, was ein Sonderuntergang und dann wieder ein Aufgang. Ich finde es seltsam, ob das mal Schlaflabore oder so, Schlafwissenschaftler, die lustigsten und spaßigsten aller Wissenschaftler mitgeholfen haben, das zu entwickeln oder? Das kann schon sein, ja, man ist ja schon, aber kann man denn eigentlich auch sich, wie schnell muss man sich bewegen, dass es nie Nacht wird? Ein Flug reicht, vollkommen. Aber ein Flug ist ja schneller als die Erde, als die Erdrotation, oder? Ja. Na, was istkreis der Erde, so 40.000 Kilometer oder so? Und 40.000 Kilometer durch 24 Stunden sind ... Und du kannst 1.000 km h fliegen. Könnt ihr euch selber ausrechnen. Also, Textrechnaufgabe, Schüler, Hefte raus. Also, wenn die Erdumdrehung ... Blitzprüfung. Ja, man ist schon sehr fremdbestimmt. Die Fluggesellschaft legt einfach fest, Stefan Tietzes Tag beginnt heute um die Uhrzeit. Ich liebe das. Aber generell auch die Himmelskörper beeinflussen uns, wann der Tag überhaupt losgeht. Wir haben uns das ja nicht ausgesucht, sondern das ist einfach so. Und jetzt gibt es ja die Leute, die sagen, wir sollen die Sommerzeit abschaffen. Ich sage Sonne abschaffen. Die Leute, ihr könnt doch nicht die Sonne beeinflussen. Ihr könnt doch nicht der Sonne sagen, wann sie aufzugehen hat. Ich finde, man hat sich da aber schon für das Richtige entschieden. Weil ich würde mich unwohl fühlen, die ganze Zeit in der Winterzeit, auch wenn es nichts ändert, wirklich, aber in der Winterzeit leben, Winter brr. Können wir nicht einfach zwei Tage für eine Hellphase machen, dass das alles so ein bisschen beschleunigt wird, so ein bisschen Fahrt reinkommt einfach. Du meinst wie bei Hühnern? Ja, tags, zwei Stunden. Damit die zwei Eier legen, hat man ja in der Käfighaltung gesagt, ja, dann lassen wir mal die Sonne ein bisschen häufiger mal auf und unter gehen. Und die Hühner sagen, gut, dann legen wir zwei Eier. Das ist einfach ein geiler Nature-Hack. Ist eine geniale Idee, aber sehr anstrengend für Morningshows, die halt dann auch doppelt so viel Content rausballern müssen. Und die müssen sich ja ohnehin schon Content aus den Fingern saugen. Und so einfach zweimal am Tag, ja, der Verbrecher ist immer noch auf der Flur. Der Hahn wird auch heiser. Ja. Das ist ja immer das Jingle der Morningshow. Was ich immer nicht verstehe ist, es gibt doch mehr als einen Hahn auf dem Bauernhof. Warum nur einer schreit? Also ist das dann wie beim Torwart, wo man warten muss, bis der stirbt, bis der nächste Torwart sein darf? Also wo der wirklich immer so sagt so, du, du, Lehmann, wie wärst du mal mit Rauchen? Also dass du mal wirklich irgendwie genießt das Leben, mal so ein, ... Nee, nee, nee, ich hab gerade erst aufgeheizt. Quatsch, Mensch, du machst so viel Sport und du bist immer so auf Achse. Willst du nicht mal ... Leg doch mal die Gurke, leg doch mal die Banane weg hier, nimm doch mal so ein schönes Sneakers. Genieß dein Leben. Nee, ich bin ein Probisportler, ich werde noch ein bisschen länger fit bleiben. Quatsch, du hast doch alles erreicht, Champions League, Weltmasterschaft. Was ist denn da mit dem Baseballschläger für heute an dem Rücken? Nee, ich ich meine einfach nur, dass es einfach, vielleicht können wir mal auf den Platz gehen. Was ist morgen auf eine Runde Baseball oder was? Nee. Warum wirkt man eigentlich in deinem Van? Du fährst doch sonst in diesen sportlichen, coolen Kia Sorento. Warte mal, ich gehe mal ganz kurz raus. Du bleibst mal ganz kurz hier drin. Gut, ich bleibe mal drin. Ortswechsel. Katu zwei Jahre später.
Und jetzt bin ich nämlich der, der dich verletzt. Aber das brauchen wir ja jetzt nicht ausspielen. Aber ich denke mir wirklich so, du hast als Torwart, bist du halt wirklich superbestimmt davon, ob es schon einen krassen Torwart gibt. Also wenn es halt einen super Torwart gibt, dann denkst du ja, brauche ich gar nicht erst anfangen, kann ja auch Eishockey spielen. Ich finde, Torwart ist doch eine arrogante Form von Fussballer, weil als Kind zu sagen, ich werde Profifussballer, ist ja schon ultra, da muss ja schon sehr von dir überzeugt sein, deine Fussballskills überzeugt sein und sehr viel Opfern, dann zu sagen, das reicht mir nicht, die Chancen wirklich Profifussballer zu werden sind mir noch zu hoch. Ich werde die Art Profifussballer, von denen es nur ungefähr zwei Stück gibt, die in Deutschland wirklich Erfolg haben. Ich werde Profitorwart. Ist schon echt eine Ansage. Und dann bist du auch wirklich ein guter Torwart, aber dann hat der Erste halt schon die ganzen Sticker-Deals und die T-Shirt-Deals und so, und dann sagen die, wir können jetzt nichtauschen. Und dann sitzt du halt immer auf der Bank und ich denke mir so, der dritte Torwart oder so während seiner WM, dass der sich nicht mal so, ob der sich wirklich jeden Tag aufwärmt. Aber hat der nicht den besten Job der Welt? Der fährt mit, der hat die Reise, der hat den Fun, der hat, ich glaube bei der Fußball-Nationalmannschaft ist auch das Gehalt ungefähr das gleiche, du bist am Teamfoto, du bist auch Weltmeister, Das ist ja das Geile, dass Kevin Grosskreuz hat zwei Minuten auf Platz gestanden, trotzdem ist er Weltmeister. Er wird auch angesprochen mit Herrn Weltmeister Grosskreuz. Ja, das stimmt schon. So, und deswegen ist es doch eigentlich der beste Job. Er kann trotzdem jeden Tag am Buffet stehen, er hat nicht die Verantwortung, ihm geht keiner einmal durch die Lappen, wie man Fußball sagt. Das stimmt, ja. Ich glaube schon, dass er eigentlich den besten Job hat. Das, oder ich denke mir immer so Mitglieder einer Band, die nicht die Songs schreiben und nicht irgendwie Liedgitarrist sind. Ja, die einfach so mitgezogen werden. Sagen wir mal, der Bassist von Green Day hat, eigentlich hat er das beste Leben, der ist Multimillionär mit der Sicherheit, in der erfolgreichsten Bands des Planeten. Ist auch auf dem Poster? Immer auf dem Poster, alle kennen seinen Namen, hat nicht einen Song geschrieben und ist ein okayer Bassist, aber jetzt auch nicht Weltklasse. Du weißt ja auch als Zuhörer immer nicht, wer da die Songs schreibt, außer du bist jetzt irgendwie Hardcore-Fan, aber so denkst du halt, ja, die machen da alle mit. Aber ich glaube auch, der zweite Bassist von Greendale will da auch ran. Greendale?
Greendale.
Hat hier jemand Butter auf die
Treppe geschmiert?
Nein?
Wir brauchen neun Bassisten.
Aber guter Beat.
Aber guter Beat, das kommt in unseren nächsten Songs.
Selbst beim Runterfallen wird er schneller.
Oh. Der Notarzt kannfallen wird er schneller. Oh.
Der Notarzt kann auch Gags machen.
Oh, geil.
Wahnsinn.
Stefan hat sich anstatt der klassischen Reaktion
auf einen Witz des Lachens für das
Oh, geil entschieden,
was in Comedy-Clubs eher
mässig ankommt. Stimmt, ich kriege
häufig schiefe Blicke, wenn ich sage, wow,
nee, das war echt gut. Oh, geil. Und dann kriege ich Blicke und dann immer, nee, nee, das war gut. Wow, gut! Ich lache nicht, ich gebe immer das Thumbs up. Thumbs up, ja. Oder ich gehe mal auf die Bühne und klopfe ihm auf die Schulter. Du kannst einfach lachen. Sehr gut. Gut, die Hand gehen.
Glückwünschen.
Ne, was ist denn bei dir so passiert in deinem Leben?
Erzähl mal von dir.
Ja, natürlich viel los.
Du hast mich heute hier zwei Stunden sitzen lassen, weil du meinst, du hast noch was vor.
Ja, weil ich gegessen habe.
Ich habe gegessen.
Also das ist wirklich so mein Highlight der Woche gewesen.
Du hast ja gesagt, du kannst ja später anfangen. Da dachte ich mir, komm, dann hole ich mir noch ein schönes Bürstchen. Bürstchen? Und lege mir das auf den Gaumen und dann ruft er an und sagt, jetzt schnell aufnehmen, schnell aufnehmen. Aber ich lasse mich nicht hetzen. Wenn ich mal das Senfglas aufgeschraubt habe, dann wird auch erst mal sich hingesetzt. Ja, da gibt es dann keinen schnell, während man die Jacke anzieht. Hast du dann quasi, ich stelle mir gerade so vor, du hast so einen Holztisch in deiner Küche, hast du schön gedeckt, aber mit so einem Platzdeckchen, hast du schön einen Teller raufgelegt, nur die Wurst auf dem Teller, ein bisschen Senf, Senfglas, dann rechts und links Besteck, dann so ein schöner Tee hast du dir noch nebenbei gemacht, die Hand in einer typischen Teebewegung, wo man auch nicht genau weiß, schmeckt es dadurch intensiver, wir wissen es nicht. Und dann kommt meine Nachricht, können wir jetzt schon loslegen. Und du nur, nö. Und dann wird weiter gegessen. Ja, klar. Natürlich. Hast du das mit dem, also ich deck meinen Tisch nie. Nie. Ich schling es immer einfach runter. Also mein Tisch ist eigentlich 24-7 gedeckt mit, glaube ich, so 20 Amazon-Kartons. Ja, Pfandflaschen? Nee, Pfandflaschen sind im anderen Raum. Allein im Pfandraum? Pfandraum. Nicht in der Küche. Aber ich habe auch tatsächlich in meiner Küche einen kleinen Esstisch stehen, nie benutzt. Und an dem sind drei Stühle. Und es ist ja immer so, wo man denkt, wann ist der Punkt, wo man so Stühle auch einfach mal in den Keller trägt? Wo man sich denkt, Leute, ein Gast, okay, ist sportlich, aber zwei Gäste. Optimistisch, aber nicht ausgeschlossen. Zwei Gäste ist sehr unwahrscheinlich. Ich lade doch nicht zwei Gäste ein. Bin ich in der Unterzahl, in meiner eigenen Wohnung? Meist auch nicht. Also wenn ich zu zweit wäre, wenn ich zu zweit ... Nee, wenn dann mehr, hätte ich gesagt. Also wenn dann einer oder mehrere, selten zwei. Gastgeber muss immer in Überzahl sein. Wenn ich zu zweit wäre, dann würde ich mir zwei Personen einladen. Mit jeglicher Anzahl eines Gastes bist du nicht mehr in der Überzahl. Naja, wenn ich zu dritt bin, dann kann ich zwei Leute einladen. Aber wenn ich alleine bin, dann würde ich niemals zwei Leute einladen. Willst du keine WG-Party bei dir veranstalten, Ma? Vor allem, wenn du dann Leuten sagst, hey, Tommy und Freddy, dann sagst du, Freddy, Tommy kommt und Tommy,, sagst du Freddy kommt und dann sagt Freddy ab, dann ist Tommy in Panik. Es ist ein großer Unterschied zwischen einem Treffen zu zweit, wo wir treffen, wir treffen uns regelmäßig auf dem Bierchen nach der Aufnahme. Das ist eine ganz andere Art von Treffen, als wenn man sagt, wir treffen uns zu dritt und dann sagt einer ab. Dann muss man umdisponieren. Dann bin ich immer der, der auch nochmal absagt. Also wenn ich das mitbekomme. Weil ich stelle mich darauf ein, zu dritt zu sein. Und es gibt auch vor allem Freunde, ja, ich würde dich auch Freunde nennen, mit denen man noch nie alleine was gemacht hat. Ja, absolut. Es gibt Einserfreunde, es gibt Zweierfreunde und ich finde, es gehört auch zum guten Ton, dass wenn man zu dritt ist und dann zum Beispiel der Gastgeber kann ja nicht absagen, weil bei ihm zu Hause ist und dann sagt einer, ah Freddy kommt nicht, dann muss
Tommy absagen. Dann gehört es zum guten Ton,
dass Tommy sagt, ah jetzt ist mir leider auch noch was dazwischen
gekommen oder ah jetzt wirklich zu zweit
den Rummikubtisch aufbauen, lohnt sich nicht,
lassen wir es. Es gehört zum guten Ton,
dass wenn von drei einer
absagt, der zweite aufbaut. Ja, vor allem muss ein Spiel sein, damit es einen eigenen
Tisch bekommt, das ist doch die eigentliche.
Aber das beobacht ihr auch häufig.
Ich habe auch manchmal eine Freundin, die ich
also, ich glaube, die würden sich gar nicht als
Freund von mir bezeichnen.
Aber ich finde, ich nehme
sie wahr als Freund von einer,
die ich in einer Gruppe habe nur.
Also immer, die hat man, wenn man in gewissen
Klicken unterwegs ist, ist dieser
Mensch dabei. Und ich verstehe
mich immer gut mit diesen Menschen, würde aber
alleine nie was mit dem machen. Ich meine,
es ist so, du kommst gerade von der Star Wars Celebration,
es ist so ein bisschen wie Chewbacca.
Du würdest nie Chewie alleine
einladen. Weißt du,
wenn man zusammen in der Clique unterwegs ist,
Chewie, Han und Carrie, alle sind
dabei, cool. Aber du würdest
nie sagen, Chewie, lass uns mal
was zusammen machen.
Du würdest nie Chewie alleine einladen, weil du hast keine Connection, du hast nur über Han die Connection. Es funktioniert nicht. Ja? Ach so. Nee, wir haben jetzt leider dann doch abgesagt, Chewie. Nee, wie gesagt, also Han hat ja abge... was? Kann ja auch alleine kommen. Was? Ist da noch jemand bei dir, Chewie? Ob Bindung schlecht. Nee, Chewie würde ich auch auf dem Treppenhaus noch nach Hause schicken. So, jetzt geht wieder. Auf diesem Moment war ich eigentlich immer nur. Nee, Chewie, lass mal. Tatsächlich, man muss absagen, wenn einer absagt. Das ist wie ein Kartenhaus. Wenn einer rauszieht, fällt alles zusammen. Man muss absagen. Hast du einen Moment, also vor allem, man hat ja keine neuen Freunde mehr. Ab einem gewissen Alter kommen selten neue Freunde dazu. Da kommen dann Kollegen. Wünschst du dir manchmal, mit jemandem befreundet zu sein? Ich hab das mit. Wer gerne mit jemandem befreundet? Oder ich weiß nicht genau. Du, wir können das große Podcast-Ufo-Freundesuche machen. Bewerbt euch, wenn ihr mit Stefan Tietze befreundet sein wollt. Ich wünsche mir sowas wie, weil ich hatte im letzten Jahr nicht viel Privatleben durch Beruf. Gebe mich ganz offen und ehrlich zu, wir sind ja auch ehrlich hier beim Podcast-Ufo. Und lassen auch manchmal tief blicken. Und ich wünsche mir sowas wie, nach so einem Jahr, wo man dann auch viele Freunde verloren hat, weil man sich nicht mehr gemeldet hat, wünsche ich mir dann sowas wie, es klingt ein bisschen trauriger als es soll eigentlich, aber wünsche mir sowas wie Tinder, nur für Freunde. Rein platonisch, rein, ich will einfach nur, was hast du für Interessen, was habe ich für Interessen, wir können zusammen in den Zoo, also dass man sowas schreibt, aufschreibt so, was man gerne machen würde. Das gibt es hundertprozentig. Also auf die Idee ist schon jemand gekommen bestimmt. Weil sie so genial ist, meinst du? Ja. Ja. Also das fände ich ja noch unangenehmer als ein Date. Ist ein Freundschaftsdate. Wahnsinnig. Weil bei einem Date, da weiss man zumindest so dieses, ja wenn man sich nicht mag, dann lässt man es halt. Aber bei Freunden ist es so ... Du hast Tom Wright geswiped, weil Tom liebt auch DSA zum Beispiel und diese Asienudeln, die du so gerne magst. Und Tom ist auch dafür zu haben für einen lustigen Netflix-Abend. So, und dann hast du Tom jetzt mal bei dieser App Wright geswiped und dann trefft ihr euch verabredet für einen Abend. Und du wirst doch trotzdem, kannst du mich erzählen, super nervös, wenn Tom gleich kommt. Tom steht gleich vor der Tür und du machst dich doch trotzdem schick. Ja und dann am Ende. Auch wenn es rein platonisch ist. Klar, du räumst die Pfannenflaschen auf und am Ende dann so, und wollen wir uns nochmal sehen? Und er lehnt sich sofort zum Kuss und du, wow, Moment. Das war platonisch. Ja, das ist ein platonischer Kuss. Hey. Moment mal, wie hieß die App? Grinder. Tinder für Freunde. Ja, ich glaube, es ist schwierig, aber sowas gibt es ja. Es gibt es zum Beispiel in der fantastischen Serie, die wir immer wieder empfehlen, Nathan for You, gibt es auch eine Folge, wo er sich einen Freund sucht über Cralist und so, oder irgendwie so ein Portal. Es gibt immer wieder dieses Portal in der Serie, wo sie Leute finden.
Das ist so grossartig. Wir brauchen Leute für eine Datingshow und dann kriegen die hunderte Zusendungen.
Ich suche einen Freund, kann auch Leute-Zusendungen. Grossartig.
Das gibt es gleich in Deutschland, gleich gar nicht, hat sich nicht durchgesetzt oder ist nie rübergekommen. Aber einfach so Leute finden die Ehe. Einfach generell, ich suche Leute. Und jetzt nicht Dating, sondern einfach für alles Mögliche. Und da hat er auch jemanden gesucht, einen Freund, auch rein platonisch. Und er hat auch die ganze Zeit so eine leicht sexuelle Stimme schon gehabt. Ja. Weil dieses Treffen verabreden, wollen wir uns nochmal sehen. Ich finde das wahnsinnig lustig. Und ich finde, da muss auch die, da fühlt man sich manchmal so, wenn man seine Männlichkeit beweisen und so. Aber es gehört auch zur Männlichkeit, sich eingestehen zu können, dass man einen Mann noch mal gerne sehen möchte als Freund. Ja. Ich würde gerne mit dem Mann mehr Zeit verbringen in meinem Leben. Ja, absolut. Du, du kannst das ja machen. Es gibt diese App hundertprozentig. Und dann kannst du dir mal erzählen. Okay, erzähl ich mal von meiner Erfahrung. Aber hättest du nicht Angst, dass dann irgendwie Leute dich dann nur wegen deinem Fame swipen und dann hast du diese ganzen Fragen und ah.
Das würde ich nicht rein, nee, deswegen würde ich kein Ganzkörperfoto von mir reinstellen, damit man mich nicht wegen meiner Optik, wegen mir als Name.
Und ich würde mich auch nicht Stefan nennen, sondern Tim.
Ist ein interessanter Punkt, würde man Freunde auch nach dem Bild aussuchen wollen? Oder was sind da dann die Kriterien? Ist es nur Hobbys oder so?
Also warum brauchst du ein Bild von mir, wenn wir nur befreundet sind? Ja, ich geb zu, die F hat doch so ein paar sexuellen Komponenten. Aber ich mein, wonach geht man denn, wenn nicht ... Also, wonach will man denn überhaupt gehen? Ja, nach Hobbys und Interessen. Ja gut, aber angenommen, Carsten sagt jetzt, ich will dich treffen, dann sagst du, nee, also, welchen potllen Gründe könntest du angeben? Wie schon wegen des Namens, Left Swipen. Jemand den falschen Namen angeben, würde ich auch nie. Aber wäre es nicht einfacher, sich direkt in einer Gruppe zu treffen? Also nicht zu zweit, weil zu zweit ist halt so dieses Dateige so ein bisschen, dass man einfach sagt, zu viert, schön bowlen, zu viert. Und dann hat man mal so da Marius und Jonathan. Aber die kennen sich schon? Ne, ne, alle vier sind neu. Oder kann man sich auch als zweier Kumpels einloggen? Nein, lass Carsten zurück, nur weil er sich nicht, der meldet sich nicht mehr. Du musst ihm nicht jeden Tag schreiben. Okay, das wird gruselig. Man trifft sich zu viert und dann ist es auch nicht so, ah, ich mag dich nicht, ich mag dich nicht, sondern man ist zu viert und dann findet man sich schon. Und dann trifft sich die Gruppe noch mal, aber ohne einen. Die Gruppe hat beschlossen, einen nicht mehr dabei haben zu wollen. Ja, denn du wurdest aus der WhatsApp-Gruppe entfernt. Oh, was? What? Aber das ist dann, glaube ich, weil dann kann man irgendwie hemmungslose Leute kennenlernen. Und dann ist es auch so, ah, okay, mit dem habe ich mich am besten verstanden. Da kann man dann im zweiten Schritt noch mal auf ein Freundschaftsdate gehen. Ja, die Frage ist dann, wann fragt man nach Handynummer und so so, ist auch bei Freunden. Das macht die App, die App generiert direkt eine WhatsApp-Gruppe mit allen vier drin und dann kannst du dir schon mal das Bildschirm angucken. Auch direkt mit dem lustigen Namen, direkt die Chaos-Crew, die Tigerbande. Es gibt hundertprozentig eine KI, die mittlerweile auch lustige WhatsApp-Gruppen-Namen erstellen kann, das ist kein Problem. Direkt Pillen-Emoji, Spritzen-Emoji, die lustigen drei Fragezeichen. Die vier Fragezeichen. Die vier Ausrufezeichen. Die drei Hashtags. Das ist zu oft um die Ecke gedauert. Die KI ist zu lustig für den menschlichen Humor. KI ist zu lustig, da mussten wir sie abschalten, riesen Terror gewesen. Ich glaube, das funktioniert, dann chattet man so ein bisschen. Weil zum Beispiel, wenn man jetzt eher so introvertiert oder schüchtern ist, glaube ich, ist es sehr unangenehm, in einem Zweierfreundschaft Situation zu sein, weil ja immer dann der andere reden muss und man selber nicht und dann denkt man, ah, interpretiert der das jetzt als, ich mag ihn nicht oder so. In Zweierdynamiken echt immer Probleme. Genau, deswegen Viererdynamik, da kann auch ein Schüchtern einmal zurücksehen und wenn es dann irgendwie um, keine Ahnung, M&Ms geht, ein Thema, wo man sich dann total einbringen kann, dann kann der Introvertierte aufblühen. Also wenn ich, ich glaube, teilweise haben wir so wie Borderline oder Asperger oder so, haben wir beide, glaube ich. Ich weiß auch nicht mehr, ob das Gespräch, was du gerade für ein Relatable ist für Leute, aber angenommen. Ich glaube, es ist sehr Relatable. Ich meine, was jetzt kommt, weil wenn du jetzt ein Zweiergespräch führst, mit jemandem, den du nicht so gut kennst, wo dann auch keine Vertrauensbasis da ist oder sowas, wo man eine History hat, wo man quasi ein Repertoire an Themen hat, auf die man immer zurückgreifen kann, denke ich die ganze Zeit darüber nach, wie komme ich, also A, wie komme ich aus dem Gespräch raus, B, wenn es noch nicht angebracht ist, aus dem Gespräch rauszukommen, weil das Gespräch gerade erst begonnen hat, oder andere Gründe, was sage ich als nächstes, wenn die Pause einsetzt, weil ich kann keine Stille ertragen in diesem Gespräch. Das ist das Unangenehme. Wie lasse ich es nicht so aussehen, als würde ich das Gespräch jetzt nur als Selbstzweck laufen, weil dann kannst du ja Fragen, und was arbeitest du? Du kannst ja unendlich viele Fragen stellen, die gehen dir ja nie aus. Du kannst sagen, und wie war deine Schulzeit so, welche Lehre hattest du? Und wenn Person B anfängt, über das Wetter zu sprechen, sowas wie, du hast kalt geworden, dann hast du verloren. Das ist eigentlich dein Game Over. Das ist so, als ob dir ein Endgegner sagt, du hast jetzt alle drei Leben aufgebraucht. Dann hast du auch nichts mehr verloren in diesem Gespräch. Ja, stimmt. Das ist seine Art, zu sagen, dass das Gespräch langweilig ist. Aber kann man nicht eine App bauen, die vier Leute verbindet? Also eine App bauen wie Tinder, die zwei Leute verbindet, ist ja einfach. Du matchst mich, ich match dich. Aber wenn du vier hast, also wenn du jeden einzelnen der drei ... Na klar, da geht es. Wenn du alle anderen geswiped hast und die auch wiederum, es ist ja dann recht unwahrscheinlich, dass alle vier zusammenkommen, aber man kann ja so zwei Matches müssen nicht stimmen. Und dann wird man so, you have a group match. Und dann kommt man zu vier zusammen. Ja, Jungs, was geht ab? Es beginnt lustig, es klingt auch lustig, es beginnt so ein bisschen wie wahrscheinlich damals Chatroulette oder so, wie eine lustige Idee, mit dann halt einfach eine Gangbang-App, wo einfach Leute sich für Gangbang treffen, das ist problematisch. Ich glaube, vielleicht brauchst du ja nur drei Leute. Drei Leute reichen ja schon. Dann hast du halt irgendwie, musst du halt dann diese sechs Verbindungen. Ja. Die müssen stimmen. Die müssen stimmen. Und das kriegt man hin. Können wir das nicht, können wir das irgendwie Dreier. Die App heißt Dreier. Dreier in Klammern Freunde, Freundschaftsdreier. Ne, ein Dreier, also Strich N Dreier. Ein schöner Dreier. So ein richtiger Dreier. Ja. Und dann einfach schön connected drei Leute miteinander. Aber auch gemischt geschlechtlich? Kann man eingeben, klar. Glaubst du, das ist die alte Frage, die wir noch gar nicht besprochen haben hier. Glaubst du, Männer und Frauen können befreundet sein miteinander? Ja. Aber ich meine, du kannst dir dann eingeben zum Beispiel, ich will mindestens eine Person, die dasselbe Geschlecht hat wie ich. Oder halt so, du kannst dir dann Parameter eingeben. Und so wird dann die Gruppe zusammengestellt. Das ist eine geniale Idee.
Ja. Und zum Beispiel auch dieses, wenn du bei Tinder matchst und dann hast du ja
dieses Chatfenster und dann sagst du halt so, ja.
Das ist einfach diese lustige WhatsApp-Gruppe,
die auch schon einen Verlauf hat, würde ich sagen.
Ja. Wo man schon so tut, als hätte man eine History.
Die letzte Gruppe, die abgebrochen hat,
die wird direkt fortgesetzt,
sodass man direkt so, oh, wie wir bei Bowen.
Einfach direkt Football-Ergebnisse, so Buddy-Talk hat. Ja., wie liest man Vanessa, einfach, dass man so schön schon eine History hat. Es gibt ja die Serie Master of None von Aziz Ansari, die so ein bisschen auch auf dieses moderne Ja genau, die so ein bisschen auf dieses moderne Daten, Daten und Technik und so auch eingeht. Aziz Ansari hat ja auch so ein Buch geschrieben, Modern Romance, wo es auch viel darum geht, und in der Serie sieht man auch eine Folge, die besteht nur aus Tinder-Dates, und da hat sie dann auch gefragt einmal so, und die Nachricht, die du mir geschickt hast, schickst du die an alle oder nur an mich? Und er hat so, nee, nur an dich, und dann zeigt man ein Handy, und dann sieht man halt, er hat die gleiche Nachricht an alle geschickt, und die Nachricht ist, I'm going to Whole Foods, do you need me to pick something up? So, das ist die Eröffnungsline. Also so, als wäre man schon lange in der Beziehung. Ich gehe kurz einkaufen, soll ich die Übrings mitbringen? So, und der hat sie geschrieben. Und jetzt finde ich es interessant, weil es gibt auch ein Reddit zu Master of None, wo ganz oft Frauen posten, die auf Tinder genau diesen Spruch bekommen haben, was einerseits natürlich unkreativ ist, weil sie weiß, die haben den Spruch kopiert aus der Serie, aber sie sofort sagt, ey, ich mag auch die Serie und man dann sofort wieder im Gespräch ist. Also es ist genial. Es ist die Frage, wie die das meinen, die Leute dann jeweils, ob die billig kopieren oder ob die das genauso antizipieren. Das ist die Frage, aber endlich... Ich bin Master of None Fan. Naja, endlich, also entweder der andere kennt die Referenz nicht und ist beeindruckt von diesem genialen Spruch, oder er kennt, oder er oder sie kennt die Referenz und man hat sofort ein Gesprächsthema. Und ist dann ja Fan automatisch von... Das heißt, in der Serie ist der Spruch gut, in der Realität ist der Spruch noch mal eine Ebene drüber gut, weil beide Dimensionen existieren. Es ist so fast, dass die Serie einem so einen Meta-Gag an die Hand,
so eine Meta-Hilfe an die Hand gegeben hat.
Ist halt schwer auf Deutsch so ein bisschen zu besetzen.
Ich habe schon überlegt, so Whole Foods ist vielleicht...
Was von der Tanke mitbringen, ist es klar.
Ja, Tanke ist nicht schlecht, ist jetzt genau das Gegenteil von Whole Foods,
aber sowas wie, euch geht kurz noch raus, vielleicht was...
Genau, nee, es hat diese Nebensächlichkeiten,
das ist ein bisschen der Spruch erhabliert.
Ja, ja, ich weiß, also ich finde den Spruch nicht so,
der ist natürlich irgendwie lustig und sowas kriegt man vielleicht auch nicht so häufig, keine Ahnung, was Frauen so kriegen, aber es ist halt schwer darauf zu antworten. Also ich finde Lines immer gut, auf die man was antworten kann, also dem Gegenüber es möglichst einfach zu machen, das Gespräch aufrechtzuerhalten, wohingegen bei Hofwitz, man kann dann natürlich in dieser ironischen, ha ha ja, bringen mir das und das mit und wollen wir uns noch was bestellen heute Abend, dann bleibst du halt in dieser Rolle. Aber es geht nie weiter. Also von daher keine Ahnung, ob es gut funktioniert. Ich finde es gut, schon mit der ersten Nachricht abzuklopfen direkt, ob die Person Humor hat und es steht, ich mag gerne in andere so andere Dukti zu verfallen. Ja. So was wie, Oh holde meid, vermag ich es, um euer Hand anzuhalten, edles Fräulein.
Und dann kommt sie im Ducki mit?
Ja genau, wenn er zurückkommt, nee, oder Augenrollsmiley oder so ein Gif, wo einfach drei Vögel mit den Schultern zucken, dann weiss man, das funktioniert nicht.
Wohingegen, wenn er zurückkommt, oh, mein edler Ritter, ich habe seit drei Morgen auf sie gewartet, dann hat man das Gefühl, ja, da ist eine Basis. Ja, das stimmt schon. Ein Freund von mir hat immer gesagt, ich hatte immer auch eine kurze Tinderphase, hat ein Freund von mir gesagt, was er immer als Eröffnung macht und er immer so appelliert so ein bisschen an so Relatable Sachen, wie zum Beispiel, hey, kann ich dich auf eine Capri-Sonne einladen? So, und das würde dann gut funktionieren, weil man kennt ja Capri-Sonne und ha, ha, ha, Kindheit, neunziger, lockig, fröge Sprüche, aber durchaus direkt, also durchaus okay, da kann was passieren, keine Ahnung. Ich würde jetzt gerne ein paar coole Sprüche als Tipps an alle Hörer geben, aber keine Ahnung. Ihr trefft euch eher auf Dreier, auf schönen Freundschafts-Dreier, auf schönen Dreier ohne Anfassen, auf der neuen Erfolgs-App. Sie wirkt gerade betont platonisch, also so wie die Tüten, die man von Sexjobs bekommt. So betont unauffällig, sodass sie auffällig sind wieder. Kann man irgendein Wortspiel machen für die App? Irgendwie ein Plato? Plat-Höhlengleichen ist. Platonisch. Ein bisschen zu um die Ecke. Kennst du diese neue App, das Höhlengleichnis? Ich weiß nicht. Man müsste mal eine Marktforschung machen, ob Leute wirklich weniger Hemmungen haben, auf ein Gruppendale zu gehen, als mehr, weil du kannst halt schon einfach der Depp. Machst du deine Gruppenidee? Ich würde das gerne mit freundschaftlichem Tinder machen. Wobei, du meinst, das gibt es ja schon. Lass uns einfach mal jeder 500 Euro in die Hand nehmen. Jeder startet eine, und dann können wir mal gucken in dem Monat, wer mehr Erfolg hat. Falls App-Entwickler zuhören, klaut uns bitte diese Idee, aber schreibt uns irgendwo so in den Mass-Tead mit rein oder so was, so dass wir so ein bisschen dabei sind, und dann in einem Monat treffen wir uns wieder, wessen App mehr Nutzer hat. Ich würd gerne mal eine App machen, wo dann vorne direkt steht, der Name, kommt der App, und dann direkt bei Stefan Thieze. Ja, oder erst mal Credits. Drei Jahre bei Stefan Tietze, erst mal die Credits. Ja, Art Director, Stefan Tietze, Written by Stefan Tietze, falsche Einstürme auch. Wie die Studentenfilme, wo man weiß, wenn der Name jetzt noch dreimal auftaucht, dann ist der Film nicht gut. Ja, genau, Introducing Stefan Tietze. You can't do anything, wo man auch irgendwann fragt, wann gehst du dazu über, zu sagen, alles, Stefan? Ja, stimmt schon, ja. Das ist einfach zusammenzufassen. Einfach, abspannend einfach, hey Leute, ich habe ja einfach alles gemacht, ciao. Alles außer dieser eine Soundeffekt, den habe ich geklaut. Den ist von so einem Ton, ciao. Du warst aber bei Ansi Sansari. Ich war bei Ansi Sansari. In Berlin, war er gestatupt. War ganz gut, einige Leute getroffen, man ist ja da so ein bisschen logenhaft dabei. Ich saß beim Fussvolk damals bei Bill Burr. Man kennt das. Ich saß einfach mitten im Fussvolk, habe herzlich gelacht. Vor allem, als Bill Burr sich darüber lustig gemacht hat, dass man als Deutscher bescheuert sein muss, seine Gene zu testen. Weil er meinte, ihr kommt von hier. Weil es ein guter Punkt ist. Weil in Amerika weiß man nicht, von wo man kommt. Und du hast besonders laut gelacht. Ich habe sehr laut gelacht und mir hat jemand gesagt, auch am lustigsten war Stefan dieses Lacher auf Dustbit. Was ein bisschen gemein ist, ging mir bei Burr. Aber es war auch tatsächlich, hat mir der Arm nicht so gut gefallen bei ihm. Muss man auch mal sagen. Oh, okay, okay. Ansonsten ist natürlich wahnsinnig viel passiert. Game of Thrones geht wieder los, ne? Okay, ich sag mal nix. Ich habe die Folge schon gesehen, wir spoilern hier ja nicht. Hast du gesehen? Habe ich schon gesehen, ja, natürlich, mir schon reingeguckt.
Ich nicht.
Ja.
Nee, es war, viele erlebt, das hast du schon recht, ich war im Kamm, das war sehr schön,
leider ist der Flug ausgefallen.
Ja, aber erst mal natürlich, für alle, die es bis jetzt noch nicht gemerkt haben, Stefan Tietze lebt.
Er lebt.
Er ist am Leben, er ist nicht abgestürzt, er ist hier.
Ich bin da. Nee, es hat leider nicht hingehauen.
Ich war sehr traurig, ich wäre sehr gerne geflogen.
Aber warum hat es nicht geklappt?
Weil es sich eine Wolke gebildet hat.
Wo ich auch gesagt habe, damit konnten wir nicht rechnen.
Ja, da habe ich auch noch so gedacht,
wenn eine Wolke ein Problem gewesen
wäre, hätten wir das nicht
vielleicht von vornherein einfach lassen sollen.
Wir haben es geplant aktiv. Eine Wolke war ein Problem? Naja, es hat sich dann Gewitter gebildet in Kamm. Und beim Gewitter weiß man ja nie so genau, was für Kaltfronten auf Warmfronten treffen. Und jetzt glaube ich, wir sind mit einer kleinen Maschine schon ein bisschen Risiko. Also man muss es umfliegen dann. Und es ist deswegen ein Zeitproblem. Es ist gar kein Sicherheitsrisiko ein Gewitter, weil du kannst es ja einfach umfliegen.
Sind die so langsam? Sind die so langsam? Ein Gewitter. Ja? Oder was ist jetzt die Frage? Ja, ein Gewitter. Ich glaube, die sind nicht so schnell, ja. Du kannst umfliegen oder du kannst einfach stehenbleiben in der Luft und das Gewitter vorbeiziehen lassen. Du musst dir vorstellen, das ist wie so ein Bahnübergang. Nee, ich glaube, ist schon relativ langsam und dann kann man das aber umfliegen, ist alles kein Problem,
aber das kostet halt Zeit.
Und da muss man vielleicht auch zwischenlanden und sowas,
weil das Benzin nicht mehr ausgeht und so weiter.
Macht halt die Strecke länger und das ist ja problematisch,
weil wir abends so die Premiere wollten.
Und deswegen haben wir das nicht gemacht.
Ja, und man kann es ja sagen,
Stefan Tietze und seine Serie
haben leider nicht gewonnen.
Nee, das stimmt. Für alle, die jetzt nicht googeln wollen, es war gar nicht so leicht zu finden, aber ich fand die DVD-L-Meldung sehr lustig, wo stand Deutsche Serie gewinnt Cannes Series und da war ein Bild von dir und halt von den BTF-Leuten, aber ihr habt nicht gewonnen. Aber trotzdem ist euer Bild. Und unser Bild, ja tatsächlich. Und ihr habt die, und alle haben da die Folge gesehen, zwei Folgen, aber auf Deutsch,
aber mit Untertiteln. Genau, komplett Deutsch
mit, und das war wirklich noch
heftig falsche
englische Untertitel und französische Untertitel.
Also wirklich massiv viele Untertitel,
ja. Aber es war schon ein tolles Erlebnis.
Aber man hat schon die ersten zwei Folgen gesehen, oder mittendrin?
Nee, die ersten zwei Folgen von jeder Serie.
Also da waren noch andere, Bauhaus zum Beispiel
und die deutsche Serie, die andere, die hat auch einen Preis für die Musik bekommen, beste Musik, die hat mir auch sehr gut gefallen, eine ganz tolle Serie, also da könnt ihr euch drauf freuen, auf jeden Fall, mit August Diehl auch. Und dann habt ihr euch auch die... Wo ich die ganze Zeit gerufen habe, hey Dieter Elström! Ah! Und dann habt ihr euch auch die ganzen anderen Serien angeguckt, dann auch die ganzen norwegischen und so? Ja, genau, also unser Screening war gleichzeitig mit den Norwegern, die hatten auch nur ein 30-Minuten-Format, deswegen war das zusammen, und dann habe ich noch zwei andere Serien gesehen, drei andere Serien gesehen, ja. Und hält man sich da so ein bisschen zurück mit dem Lachen und Klatschen, weil man, weil ja nur die anderen Man ruft aktiv Bu. Man ruft aktiv Bu. Man ruft aktiv, unsere Serie ist besser auf Norwegen. Ja, genau. Und versucht aktiv so mit einer Taschenlampe auffällig, mir ist mein Handy runtergefallen, um das zu manipulieren. Ganz laut Popcorn. Das sind Tricks, aber die kennen ja auch alle. Das sind wie beim Sport, wo man auch versucht, irgendwie so ein bisschen die Spieler zu blenden. Das war schon echt toll. Nebenbei war auch die MIP-TV, das ist die weltgrösste Fernsehformatmesse. Und das Geile ist, da ist dann auch Brainpool und so,
die jetzt aufgekauft worden von BunnyJay,
aber ganz viele, auch deutsche Firmen und ZDF war da, Arte war da
und halt so komische belgische Firmen und so,
die dann einfach Formate entwickeln und die dann verkaufen.
Man muss sich das vorstellen, das ist einfach eine langweilige Messe,
wo du nichts umsonst bekommst, also das ist nicht wie bei der Fibo,
wo du Sachen Riegel da geschmissen bekommst oder bei der Möbelmesse, wo du Sachen kaufen kannst oder keine Ahnung. Nein, das ist einfach nur eine Messe mit ganz vielen Ständen, auch teilweise coolen, grossen Ständen, die toll aufgemacht sind, aber dann haben die einfach einen Katalog da liegen und dann kannst du den Katalog zeigen und ein Format kaufen. Aber das ist schon cool, also wenn wir Bock hätten zum Beispiel, wir könnten die Patreon-Einnahmen nehmen und so ein afghanisches Format kaufen und sagen einfach hier, das klingt lustig, Frauensteinigen finden wir toll, das können wir dann machen. Aber was kostet denn, also ist das dann wirklich so ein Katalog, wie so ein Quellekatalog, wo dann so die Preise auch dabei stehen? Es sind wirklich, man sagt Katalogformate dazu, respektier dich ein bisschen, dachte ich, nein, es sind wirklich Katalogformate, das sind einfach Stände und die haben Katalog, unter anderem die französische Firma Comedy H. Comedy H. Und Comedy H hat Comedy-Formate auf der ganzen Welt verkauft, unter anderem so ein neuartiges versteckte Kameraformat. Dann hast du so große Plakate oder halt Katalog, hast dann immer so ein Bild, wo das Format schon ausgestrahlt wurde, da steht darunter irgendwie die Einschaltquoten, darunter steht dann immer, weiß ich nicht, Factual oder sechs mal dreissig Minuten und darunter steht dann immer, wie gut es lief und wie man das für den Preis, wo man die Rechte kauft. Ja, und was kostet das ungefähr? Also ist das denn so im Millionenbereich oder kriegst du da für den Hunni auch mal irgendwie so einen Wetterbericht?
Ich glaube, wenn die Vermeite noch nicht so erfolgreich über irgendwo liefen, dann glaube ich, kriegst du auch ordentlich, für sehr wenig Geld ordentliche Formate. Es gibt ja für alles Mögliche dann Messen. Es ist ja wirklich für alles, was es gibt auf der Welt, gibt es auch eine Messe. Das Tolle war, dann kannten wir da jemanden auf dieser Messe und dann, die leben einfach das Luxusleben. Dann wurden wir da eingeladen und waren so im Empfang von dieser Firma und dann konnten wir auf den Kanna Yachthafen schauen und ganz kostenlos kannst du dich betrinken mit den besten Weinen und Bieren und so weiter. Die kriegst du dann da und dann kannst du über die Croisette laufen, heißt das, wo du auch tausend Leute kennenlernst und die auch dich kennen und die beziehungsweise die Personen, mit der wir da unterwegs waren, kannten die halt alle, weil die sich halt jedes Jahr zweimal da treffen, weil diese Messe jedes Jahr zweimal ist, weil es so viele Formate offensichtlich gibt. Und dann trifft man sich immer am Grand Hotel oder am Martinez. Das ist so eine ganz kleine Strasse nur, wo sich aber alle treffen, alle kennen und alle laufen so angetrunken über diese Strasse direkt an der Côte d'A vorbei. Das ist schon echt eine irre Stadt, die sehr viel Ausland probiert, Hummer probiert. Es ist wirklich einfach eine seltsame Parallelwelt, wo ich froh bin, dass ich da jetzt ein bisschen raus bin. Aber es ist so ein bisschen des Hollywood-Europas, oder? Schon, ja. Ich glaube schon. Krass. Aber das Hollywood-Europa ist halt sofort boring, weil du niemanden kennst. Ja, mich hätte so interessiert, was das billigste Format ist, wirklich über die Messe zu gehen und zu sagen, was ist das billigste Format? Snooker, Snooker für 1,60 oder so. Bin ich so, komm, nimm Fünfer. Bin ich so, wirklich ganz billig, einfach so völlig. Komm, mir heißt er zwei. Da ist ein Typ auf einem Pogostick und der versucht, von einem Hula-Hoop-Reifen in den nächsten zu springen. Ja, mach mal einen Zehner, komm, nimm Zehner. Ja, vor allem, es gab halt die Riesenstände. Also, Bunny Jai und Brainpool hat das Fangen-Format von Luke verkauft. Das war überall in Cannen plakatiert. Fangen, riesig groß. Aber dann gab es halt auch so kleine Kackstände. Luke Mockridge hat Fangen erfunden? Ich glaube, ich weiß nicht, ob er das erfunden hat oder ob es so ein Brainpool war. So mit Abklatschen oder was? Ja. Das hat Luke Mockridge erfunden. Also was wir damals in der Schule gespielt haben, es war einfach nur eine Luke Mockridge richtig viel Geld. Ja, richtig viel Geld. Krass. Wobei ich nicht, ich habe es damals für meine Kindergarten-Abbisby gekauft. Die Formatrechte gekauft. Und er hatte Lizenz. In Cannes. Ja, und dann gibt es aber auch so kleine Kackstände halt, neben großem Catch das Form Format, gibt es auch so kleine Scheissstände, die einfach dann schlechte Formate für sehr wenig Geld verkaufen. Das ist ja wirklich faszinierend. Das ist faszinierend. Aber das so, und da war auch niemand Kreatives auf dieser Messe. Ich dachte, ich kann aber eben die Leute irgendwie Ballentherr werfen und ein cooles neues Format entwickeln. Nö, das sind halt nur knallharte Salesmenschen. Das ist denen scheißegal, was die da verkaufen. Dass Dass es Fernsehenformate sind, das ist denen scheißegal. Das sind einfach so knallharte Verkäufer. Die könnten auch Sneaker verkaufen oder, weiss ich nicht, Bonsai-Bäume. Das ist denen ganz egal. Auch was für eine Messe die da sind, das ist denen scheißegal. Das ist einfach so eine austauschbare Masse an Menschen. Verkäufer, gute Verkäufer. Krass, das ist nicht schlecht. War das dann wirklich so die Oscar-Ghost-To-Award oder habt ihr das so? Es gab eine große Abschlussveranstaltung, die wurde sogar übertragen auf Canal Plue. Und es war alles auch französisch, ich habe nichts verstanden. Wobei, bei der Abschlussveranstaltung hatten wir dann so große Kopfhörer, die man sich einstecken kann, wo es live übersetzt wurde. Das war ganz cool, ja. Das heißt, während es heißt And the Oscar Goes To habt ihr alle Hörer am Kopf,
um dann zu hören, Stéphane
Tisset. Tisset? Oh lala!
Und dann kommt er auf die Bühne.
Nee, wie gesagt, wir haben nichts gewonnen.
Aber habt ihr denn eine Rede auf Französisch
vorbereitet, oder wäre das dann...
Nee, die kannst du dann auf Englisch halten, dann können sich die
Franzosen-Bourgeois, können sich dann
diese Telefon ins Ohr stecken und dann wird es für die
auf Französisch übersetzt.
Schon lustig.
Aber hatte die eine Rede? Nee.
Und dann ist es für die auf Varsölich übersetzt. Schon lustig. Aber hatte die eine Rede? Nee. Ihr hättet es einfach nicht mehr gesehen. Niemand hat auch eine Rede, das war relativ schnell und fix alles. Einfach bedanken bei irgendwem. Das war schon der Beeindruckende, trotzdem das ganze Erlebnis, das mal vom Publikum zu zeigen, auch international. Und dann hast du halt auch wirklich ein Riesenkino und einen coolen Sound. Das war schon cool. Stefan Tietze, Mensch, kommt rum für alle Fans, die jetzt ein bisschen Interesse haben. 31. Mai geht's los. 31. Mai ist ja Launcher-Serie auf Netflix. Alle Folgen oder dann eine nach der anderen? Alle sofort online, die kann man schnell wegbinden. Man kann direkt am 31. Mai alles wegbinden. Alles wegbinden, ja. Wird auch schnell gehen. Das ist ja nicht so viel. Gibt's da Binge-Partys? Gibt's da schon Fanclub und so? Nö, aber könnt ihr ja auch auf Dreier auf der App, könnt ihr das ja organisieren. Ja, genau, ihr binget zu dritt. Pünktlich zum Lounge. Drei ist eine gute Binge-Sache. Schön Netflix und Chill. Ja, nee, Stefan. Mit den Torsten und Timo. Netflix and Friends. Netflix and Friendship. Netflix, chill and friendship. Ich habe viele Nachrichten bekommen, dass es auch missverstanden wurde. Netflix and chill ist ja, wie wir alle wissen, Synonym für Sex haben. Ja, wo ich mir auch nicht hundertprozentig sicher bin, ob das so stimmt. Aber ja, okay. Aber kommt das daher oder wurde es dann aufgegriffen? Weil kommst du hoch auf einen Kaffee,
war ja auch mal wirklich einfach ein ernst gemeinter Vorschlag, einfach
Kaffee zu trinken oder nicht und
irgendwann wurde es dann so
zum quasi geflügelten Wort. Aber ich hatte
es nie so verstanden, dass man
Sex hat, während die Serie läuft.
Sondern ich dachte halt so, man sagt
das so als Vorwand, wie Kaffee trinken
und vielleicht schaut man dann wirklich eine Folge Bosch oder was auch immer an.
Siemens.
Und dann wie jetzt?
Du dachtest, man hat Sex und guckt aber eine Serie.
Nee, so hast du es ja eingeführt letzte Woche.
Nee, nee, so hast du es eingeführt.
Dass man dann irgendwie so während Staffel zwei dann irgendwann abdriftet.
Nein, das ist einfach ein Vorwand, sich zu treffen.
Du sagst, die Eltern treffe ich mit Carina, wir haben schön Netflix und chill. Und die Kondome nehme ich auch mit. Okay, verstehe. Und dann denken die Eltern auch, die gucken Netflix und pusten Kondome auf. Werbung. Oh, Stefan, irgendwie habe ich keine Podcasts mehr, die ich hören kann. Nie? Du, pass auf, ich kann dir helfen. Mit dem neuen Podcast von unserer Freundin Katjana Gerz. Katjana Gerz hat einen Podcast? Hast du etwa noch nie davon gehört? Nee, ich habe noch nie davon gehört. Der Podcast heißt Nie gehört, der Podcast, der dir eine Stimme gibt. Präsentiert wird das Ganze von Katjana, der fantastischen Schauspielerin, Komedien, Allrounderin, Tausendsasserin, Katjana Gerz, die jede Woche ausseröffentlichte Menschen empfängt. Sie ist nicht alleine, sie empfängt u.a. Warm-Upper, Lach-Yoga-Trainer oder Poetry-Slammer, aber nicht zu viele Poetry-Slammer, es hält sich in Grenzen. Dafür Donio Sullivan, der ist sehr unterhaltsam, der Podcast, und deswegen hört unbedingt rein, präsentiert wird das Ganze von Gallery Voice Haltstabletten. Deswegen auch der clevere Gag, der Podcast, der dir die Stimme gibt. Ah, jetzt verstehe ich. Das Ganze könnt ihr natürlich hören auf podstars.de, oder könnt ihr es einfach abonnieren über iTunes, Spotify und allen anderen bekannten Kanälen. Viel Spaß. Ich habe übrigens gehört, dass die bei Starbucks die extra den falschen Namen draufschreibenreiben, damit du es fotografierst und damit du Starbucks-Werbung machst. Genial. Kostenlos. Auf der anderen Seite, also klar, Reichweite, aber ein Image von dummen Mitarbeitern. Was will man denn eigentlich? Will man nicht, will man nicht, man will ja nicht dumm dastehen. Also alle unsere Mitarbeiter schreiben euren Namen falsch. Ich glaube auch, dass diese wirklich schon total abgegriffene Punchline, diese Grössen, dass irgendwie Grande ist das Kleinste und dann Venti. Kleine ist das Grösste. Nee, tall. Venti ist das Grösste, tall ist das Kleinste. Genau, tall ist das Kleinste. Dass die sowas auch absichtlich machen, dass man einfach Gesprächsstoff hat und es einfach erwähnt und wie komisch ist denn das? Und auch hunderte Comedians haben umsonst Starbucks-Werbung gemacht, in dem sie sagen, oh, Starbucks, toll, alle lachen und haben sofort, ah, lachen Starbucks sofort im Kopf. Das ist die perfekte Werbung. Und Peter Starbucks lächelt sich ins Fäustchen. Aber Peter Starbucks ist auch einfach ein Genie, weil der auch in seinen, in den Starbucks-Filialen wird das Buch verkauft, warum Starbucks so erfolgreich ist. Was für ein Ballsy-Move ist das denn? War das schon in der ersten Filiale? Ich glaube, der hat eher auch erstes Buch geschrieben und dann wurde er wirklich erfolgreich. Und die gerade aufgemacht hat erst. Ja, ich glaube, wenn du einfach ein Buch schreibst und sagst, warum ich so erfolgreich bin, wirst du automatisch erfolgreich, weil du dir denkst, ja klar, ergibt Sinn und dann wirst du auch erfolgreich. Ja. Du musst aber nur einen Ratgeber schreiben, bevor du das, wofür du Ratgeber gibst,
wirklich erreicht hast. Ich habe
bei Star Wars gesagt Stefan, Frau Stefan
und sie haben mit PH mich geschrieben.
Tatsächlich kleiner
Funfact, ich sage auch immer Stefan.
Wenn ich
bei Star Wars bin, sage ich auch Stefan.
Warum? Weil es ein
schlichter Name ist. Schlichter Name ist? Weil es ein Name ist, den jeder kennt. Und dann bin ich aber auch schon oft in dieses F oder PH reingerutscht. Und dann weißt du, was ich dann immer sage? Ist egal. Sagst du? Ja, sag ich. Was auch so ist, weil es ist ja wirklich scheißegal. Du kannst ja auch einen Kaktus draufmalen, wenn du willst. Mit P oder F. Ist egal. Ne,. Die einen sagen so, die anderen sagen so. Mach wieder willst, Schnuckelchen. Der wird rausgeworfen. Mach wieder willst, Süße. Aber ich sag auch, ich sag immer Stefan. Sag mal einfach alle Stefan. So lange bis Starbucks irgendwann merkt, alle sind Stefan. Auch wenn ihr Mädels seid. Schön hingegen sagen Stefan. Einfach alle sind Stefan. auss lange bis Starbucks irgendwann merkt man, alle sind Stefan. Auch wenn ihr Mädels seid, schön hingehen und sagen Stefan. Einfach alle sind Stefan. Außer im Ausland, der Name funktioniert nicht im Ausland. Stephan? Stephan. Auf Englisch funktioniert es nicht, Stefan sage ich dann immer. Sagt doch Steve. Ja, dann ist er S-T-E-F-V-E. F-V-V-E. Wo würdest du Steve schreiben? S-T-E-V-E. Ja, ist richtig. Ja, habe ich gerade versprochen. Oh, Gesundheit, hast du etwa Husten? Och nö, geht ein bisschen kränklich. Jetzt ist ja Sommer, geht los. Ich habe heute mal erstmal schön meine Schuhe zu Hause. Das sind schöne Birkis, aber noch mit Socken drunter. Also man muss ja auch... Also die All-In unangenehmer Mensch. Kostüm hast du ja angezogen heute. Man muss ja auch so ein bisschen auf die Gesundheit achten. Aber jetzt geht es ja los, Frühling. Ja, in Chicago, Funfact, gibt es keinen Frühling. Ich hatte in einem Tag ein Grad und Schnee und am nächsten Tag war 18 Grad und stechende Sonne. Das war wirklich extrem, das habe ich auch so noch nie erlebt. Und dann meinten die Uber-Fahrer dann schön. Wir haben mit einer Gruppe Uber-Fahrer gesprochen. Die Uber-Fahrer, eine Uber-Fahrerin war richtig sauer auf mich. Ach, Uber. Ich dachte Uber. Uber. Perfekt Werbung. Die Uber-Fahrer waren extrem sauer auf mich. Also eine Fahrerin, und zwar, das Gespräch war super nett. Ungefähr eine Viertelstunde Fahrt.
Die ersten
14 Minuten war super freundlich, super nett
gesprochen, über die Stadt gesprochen und so weiter.
Dann habe ich mich darüber lustig gemacht,
dass bei der Star Wars Celebration
ein Waffenschild draußen stand, was durchgestrichen war.
Bei jedem
Eingang waren Waffe durchgestrichen.
Und da habe ich gesagt, das ist doch
lustig, warum sollte man das denn betonen? Sollte das nicht die Default-Position sein, dass man keine Waffen mitnimmt? Man soll lieber da, wo Waffen erlaubt sind, Schilder machen, hier sind Waffen erlaubt. Das fand ich lustig. Und dann hat sie ja erst gelacht, und dann habe ich aber weiter gelacht und gesagt, ja gut, hier in Amerika ist es ja auch ein bisschen was anderes, haben irgendwie so gut wie jeder eine Waffe und so. In Deutschland hat niemand eine Waffe übrigens, weil das für viele Amerikaner oft ein Funfact ist. Und dann wurde es schlagerliches Gesicht dunkel und dann kam nur noch zurück, ja stimmt, wir schießen uns ja auch alle ab hier. Ist ja auch alles furchtbar hier, ne? Und dann war wirklich die Stimmung sofort tot und habe ich auch gesagt, nee, und die anderen haben auch noch versucht, sich zu beruhigen, haben wir gesagt, nee, das war ja gar nicht gemeint. Und habe ihr auch gesagt, nee. Und die anderen haben auch versucht, sie zu beruhigen.
Dann haben wir gesagt, nee, das war gar nicht gemeint.
Und dann, ja,
sie war relativ schnell auch weggefahren.
Mit euch drin.
Also es ist nicht so leicht, einen Abgang zu machen.
Als Überfahrer, das stimmt.
Wir hätten meine Leute transportiert.
Nein, dann war sie wirklich sauer.
Und dann ist sie mit, dass sie es rausgeschmissen,
dann war, dann war es,
dann war es raus,
raus mussten,
und ist dann mit quietschenden Reifen losgefahren.
Und ich weiß nicht, was ich für eine Bewertung von ihr bekommen habe. Ach stimmt, da kann man ja auch Leute bewerten, ne? Ja, genau. Du wirst auch bewertet. Was wirst du für eine Bewertung? Ich habe in meinem Leben noch nie Uber benutzt. Doch, klar. Nee. In Dings? Uber? Nee, das warst du mal du. Ich bin immer nur mitgefahren bei dir. Ich habe eine Bewertung von 4,91. Das ist nicht so gut. Irgendwas ist schiefgegangen. Geht besser. Das habe ich einem anderen Oberfahrer erzählt und der hat gesagt, wow, what did you do? Bevor ich dich jetzt fahre, what did you do? Dann habe ich mich auch echt gefragt, was ich gemacht habe, weil man kann als Fahrer nicht viel falsch machen. Als Oberfahrer kannst du eine Menge falsch machen. Das Auto kann furchtbar sein, du kannst unangenehme Radiosender anhaben, du kannst unangenehm sprechen, du kannst unsicher Auto fahren, so schnell Auto fahren. Als Fahrer, äh, Gefahrener, kannst du nicht viel falsch machen. Stinken. Stinken vielleicht, aber das ist kein Grund für eine schlechte Bewertung. Naja, tatsächlich bewerte ich nie. Ich baue sehr stark auf Bewertungen, also wenn ich mir was bestelle oder so, immer Bewertungen, immer nach Sternen. Aber ich gebe nie Bewertungen selber ab. Urlaube? Also es ist wirklich absolut unfair. Stimmt, tatsächlich, ich gebe nie eine Bewertung ab. Aber ich glaube, wer gibt denn Bewertungen ab? Das ist das Problem. Das macht niemand. Und dann denke ich mir eigentlich, pass auf, ich bin ein Mensch, der gibt keine Bewertungen ab. Verlasse mich aber auf die Bewertungen von Menschen, die Bewertungen abgeben. Also anderen, eine andere Art von Mensch. Also ist deren Bewertung ja gar nicht repräsentativ für meinen Geschmack. Ja, ich würde sogar so weit gehen, ich kenne niemanden, der bewertet. Das heißt, meine ganze Blase, in der ich ja auch sein will, weil ich diese Blase habe mir ja selber geschafft und suche mir diese Blase ja auch, gibt keine Bewertungen ab. Das heißt, alle Bewertungen, die man sieht, sind nicht repräsentativ für mich. Ja, und es gibt so einen Ort, ein Restaurant, wo ich ab und zu bestelle und jedes Mal, wenn der Lieferant kommt, beschwert er sich, dass er keinen Parkplatz findet. Und jedes Mal klingelt er der Tür nicht mal auf und er so, ich find hier nirgendwo einen Parkplatz, wo man denn hier parken, da unten steht, da steht alles voll, hinten kann man auch nicht parken, da ist Parkverbot, da kriegen Strafzettel. Wo wohnst du denn?
Und ich denke mir so, okay, und da dachte ich mir, ja gut, er hat einen schlechten Tag, ist ja auch wahrscheinlich ein scheiß stressiger Job, aber das macht er jedes Mal. Ich glaube, der will mich einfach
davon abhalten.
Zur schlechten Bewertung zwingen.
Oder der will mich davon abhalten, da wieder zu bestellen, um einfach zu sagen, hey,
weil ich denke mir so, es gibt ja bestimmt als Lieferant Orte, an die man lieber fährt und an die man nicht gern fährt. Und irgendwann denkt man sich bestimmt auch, wenn ich jetzt zu den Leuten, wo ich nicht gern hinfinde, ein Arschloch bin, zu denen, wo ich gern hinfahre, nett bin, dann kann ich ja mein Schicksal selber in die Hand nehmen. Und er macht sehr offensichtlich, weil er dir sagt, dass er nicht gern zu dir fährt. Ja, genau. Weil er genau das auch sagt. Aber ich dachte mir jetzt die ersten zehn Mal so, ja, der ist schon echt immer mies gelaunt, aber irgendwann denke ich mir so, ist es meine Schuld? Hat man eine moralische Verantwortung, wenn man Essen bestellt, dass man gut erreichbar ist? Gute Frage. Also, ich weiß nicht, und da habe ich mir auch gelegt, soll ich da jetzt mal eine Bewertung schreiben? Also Essen top? Fahrer immer wütend.
Aber auch verständlich, weil bei mir gibt es wirklich sehr schweren Parkplatz zu finden.
Ja, und ich gebe auch nie Trinkgeld.
Also wirklich, vielleicht liegt es eher an mir.
Lassen wir mal fünf Sterne.
Ich würde das überkompensieren, wenn es sehr viel Trinkgeld geben, glaube ich.
Ich gebe auch immer viel Trinkgeld.
Ich gebe immer richtig viel Trinkgeld.
Weil ich denke mir, die spucken immer ins Essen.
Oder werfen es auf den Boden oder so.
Foodora ist übrigens tot. Okay. Also ist gestorben, ist jetzt Lieferando. Ja. Wohingegen Uber jetzt in Köln existiert. Ah, meinst du nicht, die haben einfach sich einen anderen Hut aufgesetzt? Uber. Und dann fährst du auf so einem Fahrrad hinten mit? Ah, oh, tatsächlich Uber Eats. Das kann auch echt ein Grund sein, für Foodora zu sagen, nur wir sind hier raus.
Aber diese Essenskuriere sind auch krasse Leute, also ich habe immer das Gefühl, das sind wirklich so die Cowboys der Stadt.
Ich habe heute wirklich einen gesehen, der ist so durch die Innenstadt gepest und vor allem die haben ja diesen riesigen Kasten hinten drauf, der rechts und links noch bestimmt einen halben Meter übersteht.
Und der ist an einem kleinen Mädchen vorbeigefahren mit locker 30 km Haar.
Und das Mädchen war so gross, dass der mit dem Kasten über ihren Kopf gefahren ist.
Das Mädchen steht da und über dem Kopf kommt diese Box.
Die Haare wehen.
Wie sicher muss man seinen Fahrkünsten sein, dass man so gut abschätzen kann, wie hoch die Box ist und so eng dafür, du kannst ja nicht das Mädchen machen, einen Schritt nach hinten und ist einfach weg. Aber die sind einfach, die kennen einfach nix. Wahnsinn. Die sind echt einfach, also das sind krasse Leute, die sind einfach unter großem Stress stehen. Das ist auch so eine Wild-West-Stimmung, die haben auch diese befeindeten Teams, also wenn du auf den Libero-Fahrer triffst, ist ja auch erstmal. Die Lanze rausholen, Bats! Battle, das ist wie so ein Pokémon, da musst du auch erstmal kämpfen. Ja, die machen dann die Pizza kalt. Die haben so Kalt-Sprays, so Pizzakalt. Oh, nein! Flüssig Stickstoff. Ja, nee, und jetzt gibt es Uber. Da habe ich auch einen Uber-Fahrer gefragt, ob es Uber Eats funktioniert. Er hat gesagt, keine Ahnung, ich hole immer das Essen ab. Wenn ich jetzt als Consumer Essen bestellen will, wie mache ich das? Er hat gesagt, ich hab keine Ahnung, ich fahre das nur. Wenn Sie es mir nicht sagen, kriegen Sie einen Stern. Ich hab schon wieder zwei Sterne bekommen. Wenn Sie es mir nicht sagen, kriegen Sie einen Stern. Vier Sterne, drei Sterne, zwei Sterne, ein Stern, ich steig der Hand, du hast sie ja wirklich in der Hand. Manchmal wurde ich auch gefragt, ob ich gerne einen Radiowunsch hätte. Da habe ich auch gedacht, oder das ist jetzt so eine Trickfrage, wenn ich jetzt das Falsche sage, kriege ich da eine schlechte Bewertung. Man ist in so einem stetigen, wer bewertet die eigentlich wen-Modus. Alle sind so super nice und dann kam diese Frage auf, willst du so einen speziellen Radiosender hören? Und da habe ich gesagt, nein. Weißt du, wenn ich jetzt sage, ja, ich würde gerne laute Rockmusik hören oder schillernde Klassik, so, dann kann ja auch sein, dass er einfach dann sagt, okay, zwei Sterne, der wollte Klassik hören. Treibende, exotische Klänge mit einem Hauch Nostalgie. Treibender Tango oder flinker Flamenco?
Flamenco, das ist mir eigentlich... Machen Sie mal Flamenco an.
Sie meinen Flamenco. Ich meine Flamenco.
Vier Sterne.
Wenn Sie mir nicht sofort Flamenco anmachen.
Flamenco in fünf,
vier,
drei.
Mischung aus Tango und Flamenco.
Haben wir gerade einen neuen Tanzerfunk? Flamenco? Alternativ Tango. Flamenco oder Tango? Ich finde, Tango klingt... Tango ist halt was anderes. Tango ist nochmal eine ganz andere Art. Tango ist auch eher was zu essen. Einen schönen Tango. Tango-Bell. Bringst du mir nochmal zwei Tango mit? Von der Tango. Gibt es in Frankreich Taco Bell? Nee, da habe ich es nicht. Nee, da in Cannes sowieso nicht. In Cannes gibt es auch kein McDonald's. Da gibt es nur Yves Saint Laurent. Und Eis. Und Lacoste und Eis. Ah, lecker. Nee, da habe ich wirklich absurd gut gegessen, muss man auch sagen. Auch alles auf Kosten von anderen. Da habe ich sehr billig gelebt, aber sehr gut, das war sehr toll. In Chicago hingegen alles auf eigener Tasche, dafür nicht so gut, da habe ich dann Taco Bell gefressen jeden Abend, das war okay. Wenn ich wirklich die Wahl hätte, wenn ich ehrlich zu mir bin, zwischen so einer Hummerplatte mit Austern und so und Taco Bell, man will sagen, ja, ich bin Gourmet, ich stehe auf die Delikatessen. Wenn ich ehrlich zu mir bin, ich will lieber zu Taco Bell gehen. Ja, absolut. Ja. Absolut. Weil die tun ja da Sachen rein, die gut schmecken, nicht die gut sind. Ja, aber auch Hummer ist ja nicht gut für dich. Ausland und Hummer ist nicht gut für dich, nein. Sind da nicht so Proteine drin oder so? Es kann sein, dass Omega-3-Fettsäuren drin sind, aber das ist auch furchtbar, also Schalentiere sind nicht gut. Gut, also das ist der Gesundheitstipp für diese Woche. Leute, esst nicht zu viel Hummer, also haltet euch zurück. Wie viele Hummer pro Tag sind das Maximum? Ich verdiene auch die Leute mit Trüffel und Hummer. Übrigens, jemand hat kommentiert und hat geschrieben, ja, er hat jetzt Lust bekommen auf Trüffel und hat mal ein bisschen nach Trüffelrezepten gestöbert und hat aber bei diesen Trüffelrezepten gefunden, dass das Trüffel immer schon nach ein paar Tagen schlecht wird. Und ich reiche diese Frage an dich weiter, wie du es schaffst, Stefan, dass dein Trüffel über Monate hinweg so frisch und köstlich bleibt. Auf meinem Trüffel stand drauf, mindestens haltbar bis 2022. Okay, und du bist dir sicher, dass das Trüffel war und kein Toffee fehlt? Stefan? Nee, es war schon Trüffel. Aber wahrscheinlich hast du das bei einem richtigen Trüffelhändler gekauft, am Markt. Ein Schwein. Ein Trüffelschwein. Ja. Und dann ist es wahrscheinlich nicht so lange haltbar. Ich weiß es nicht genau. Finden die Trüffelschweine den Trüffel nur oder fressen die den auch?
Oder muss der Schweinführer sagen, muss der die wieder aus dem Mund hauen oder so?
Wo die halt so eine Hauge ist hier mal.
Ja, wenn Hunde was im Maul haben, was sie nicht im Maul haben sollen, dann haut man den ja so auf die Schnauze oben drauf.
Dann sagt man aus, sagt man aus.
Ja, das ist dem Hund doch scheißegal.
Nö.
Okay, gut. Wer hat jetzt hier einen Hund? Du. Ja, Hau dir mal so einen Stock auf die Schnauze drauf. Ja. Eigentlich muss man immer auf die Schnauze, auch beim Hai? Immer auf die Schnauze hauen. Generell immer auf die Schnauze hauen. Direkt drauf einfach, kein Problem. Einfach drauf ballern. Nee, ich glaube, die wollen das dann nicht fressen. Die finden das nur, oder was? Wollte man nach Florenz, da kann man das machen. In Florenz kann man dann in Toskana nebenan schön auf Trüffeljagd gehen mit Schweinen.
Da hast du so ein Schweinchen und dann wird schön Trüffel gesucht. Die finden das nur, oder was? Wollte man nach Florenz, da kann man das machen. In Florenz kann man dann in Toskana nebenan
schön auf Trüffeljagd gehen mit Schweinen.
Da ist so ein Schweinchen und dann wird schön Trüffel gesucht.
Aber ist es nicht auch, dass sie sagen,
wenn du heute nicht genug Trüffel findest, dann essen wir dich stattdessen?
Ja.
Und das Schwein denkt sich, shit, man,
es ist kein Trüffelfleiss drauf, man, das checken wir nicht.
Ich bin einfach in den Champing gegangen, das checken wir nicht.
Die kaufst du dann, die ganzen anderen Sachen, die das Schwein fangen. Ich bin hier im Mittelpunkt da denke ich mir, da kaufe ich jetzt einfach in dem Laden da drüben bei all diesen Trüffel und vergrabe das, damit das Schwein nicht geköpft wird. Ah ja, okay, das kann auch sein, dass du dann vor dem Schwein herläufst und diesen Trüffel vergräbst. Symbiose, verschiedene Lebewesen arbeiten perfekt zusammen. Mit was arbeitest du richtig zusammen, was ist dein symbiotisches Verhältnis mit irgendwas? Ich bin echt ein Spargel-Fan geworden, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Aber jetzt denk jetzt natürlich deine Augenbrauen schnell in die Höhe. Aber ich bin ja wirklich unterste Klasse der Spargelesser, denn für mich kommt nur auf den Teller schön Glas, schön Konserve, schön die Dose Spargel. Alle Spargelfreunde, ja,
klar, ich rieche doch schon die
Kommentare hereinflattern.
Oh, Dosen, Speise, Schlimmste, das ist doch ein anderes
Gericht. Man muss sagen, okay, dann magst du das,
das ist aber ein anderes Gericht. Naja, es ist
keine Dose, es ist ein Glas und die sind sogar recht teuer,
also da kostet so ein Glas 2,80 oder so,
wo ich mir denke, hey, die Cornichons
kosten irgendwie 79 Cent,
Ciglado, El Perforo, aber der Spargel, schön 2,80. Da denke ich mir, gut, da lege ich mir einfach ein paar auf den Teller. Und vor allem Spargel haben ja, Funfact, nahezu keine Kalorien. Ist ja auch nahezu nur Wasser. Deswegen weiß ich auch nicht, warum die sich so grosser Bliebtheit erfüllt, weil du isst ja, deswegen auch Hollandaise einfach, ist ja fast reines Fett, das du einfach drüber ballerst und dann damit es irgendwie geht. Ich denke, Spargel ist die Berechtigung, um fast einfach nur reine Butter in sich reinzuschliessen. Ja, du könntest auch einfach ein Blatt Papier nehmen und da Hollandaise drauflegen. Ja genau, aber das macht, dann sagt die Gesellschaft halt, was ein Freak. Wogegen Spargel ist einfach so akzeptiert. Aber Spargel hat eine sehr spezielle Konsistenz. Ich hatte auch diesen Spargel in der Hand und ich wobble den dann so. Das ist der Spargel-Test? Aus Spaß. Ach so, einfach Spaß. Einfach, nee, ich packe den. Ich habe einen Test, um zu gucken, ob der reif ist. Nee, nee, nee, nee, reiner Funfaktor. Ich packe den in der Mitte ab und wobble den so. Und während des Wobbelns geschah etwas Unerwartetes. Die Hülle. Der Spargel befreite sich quasi aus meinem Griff und fiel herab zu Boden, machte dabei aber eine 180-Grade-Rotation, so dass er wirklich wie ein Pfeil mit dem Kopf voraus auf den Boden gefallen ist. Also der muss so 90-Grad-Kerzen gerade auf dem Boden gefallen. Dass er sich zweigeteilt hat. Dass er sich wirklich wie, das ist wirklich schwer zu beschreiben, dass er sich so in alle Richtungen aufgeteilt hat. So wie so zipp. Also es war ganz merklich. So ein Kreis aus Spargelsplittern auf dem Boden. Ja genau, es war wirklich so ein Kreis für mich, alle Formen ungefähr gleich. Weil die haben ja so Fasern. Das ist so sonnenartig. Genau, wenn du mal den Kopf gebrochen hast, dann fasern die ja alle in ihre Richtung aus und die gehen in alle Richtungen
und es war ein bemerkenswerter Anblick,
wo du einfach aus so einer Situation des Missgeschicks
einfach so ein Wupp
und dann denkst du, was mache ich jetzt? Wow.
Weil ich habe keinen Müll, so
Punkt eins. Und jetzt denke ich mir, was mache
ich jetzt, weil
ich kann das ja nicht jetzt liegen
lassen, weil
sonst wird das ja irgendwann mal rödlich.
Du kannst ja den Punkt ansetzen, dass du keinen Müll hast. Das Problem könntest du vielleicht zuerst lösen. Nee, ich habe komplett Müll eliminiert aus meinem Leben. Wie, wie, war, war, war. Ich erzeuge keinen Müll mehr, ich konsumiere keinen Müll mehr, es gibt keinen Müll mehr in meiner Wohnung. Erst mal gut, dass du keinen Müll mehr konsumierst, vielen Dank. Alles wird wiederverwendet, direkt. Was, wie? Und naja. Wenn du jetzt so schöne, wo kommt das Glasspargel hin? Naja, also in dem Glas ist ja noch Flüssigkeit. Da wird das Alex Spargel auf den Boden geworfen, dass überall diese kleinen Sonnen rumliegen, du stehst immer auf dem Stuhl und lässt von oben die Spargel fallen, um grössere Sonnen zu erzeugen. Was machst du dann, wenn du mit dem Glas leerer Spargel? In dem Glas ist ja noch so Sud drin, ja? Klar, die Äxte weg. Sud ist einfach, kann man entweder schön weg, Äxten, Stroheim rein, Metallstroheim rein, oder halt in Abwasser, Abguss. Ja? Ja. So, das ist weg. Ja, nee, wo ist das Glas hin? Das Glas kann man ja auch in den Abguss, nein, ich meine, das tatsächlich, und da bin ich nicht stolz drauf, ich werfe auch viel aus dem Fenster, aber im Hof steht der Müll, also ich kann wirklich aus meiner Wohnung, ist es wirklich kein Witz, das ist mir ein bisschen unangenehm, ich kann aus meinem Fenster in den Container werfen und ich bin mittlerweile so gut darin geworden, weil ich dachte mir, gut, du investierst ... In den Glaskontainer? Nein, den nicht.
Den meintest du jetzt nicht. Ich freu jetzt den anderen Container.
Ich sag mal, Mülltrennung steht jetzt nicht auf Priorität Nummer eins.
Ich weiß, ich weiß, ich weiß. Ich sehe schon die Zuschriften.
Aber am Anfang, wenn du in die Wohnung einziehst und du guckst aus dem Fenster und siehst unten einen Container, denkst du dir, pass auf.
Entweder ich investiere jetzt eine Woche.
Ich bin fasziniert. Entweder ich investiere jetzt eine Woche, wo ich halt daneben werfe und ständig runterlaufen muss, aber dann kann ich es oder halt nicht. Und ich habe mich dafür entschieden, ich investiere die Woche und treffe mittlerweile, dann spart man sich auch den Weg zum Mülleimer. Ich trenne natürlich schon, wo es geht. Das heißt, ja klar, also einmal nach rechts werfen, einmal nach links werfen. Ja, drei Punkte, zwei Punkte, dank. Die Pappe ist schön wie so eine Frisbee. Ja, das musst du halt immer so ein bisschen gucken, dass die Konsistent stimmt. Okay, ich habe langsam ein Bild von dir zu Hause. Du bist der weirde Nachbar, der Dinge aus dem, der weirde, wo du langsam aus dem Unterlassungsklage kommt, der Dinge aus dem Fenster wirft und Spargel auf den Boden fallen lässt. Ich habe tatsächlich mal ausgerechnet, weil ich habe mir überlegt, das ist ja nicht erlaubt, glaube ich. Oder? Also es gibt ja kein Gesetz, das eine Mindestdistanz festschreibt, von der der Müll geworfen werden muss. Irgendwann werden Dinge, die du machst, so verrückt, dass es auch kein Gesetz mehr für gibt. Richtig. Crazy Persons haben erstmal einen Freifahrtschein. Ja, und ich denke mir, was ist, wenn das jemand sieht? Und dann habe ich mal geguckt, wie lange schaue ich am Tag aus dem Fenster. Man weint, man, du kennst ja jetzt wahrscheinlich keine... Anders mit so Augenringen und roten Bindfäden. Ja, angenommen, du stehst vor Gericht und du sagst, aha, Herr Tietze, Sie sagen also, Sie haben meine Mandantin am 4. Oktober 2017 am Bahnhof gesehen, wie sie auf den Zug gewartet hat.
Wie viele Minuten, würden Sie mal schätzen, wie viele Minuten pro Tag schauen Sie denn so aus dem Fenster? Pro Tag, sagen wir mal so eineinhalb Minuten, zwei Minuten. Pro Tag. Und jetzt sagen wir mal, Sie befinden sich in Ihrer Wohnung so ungefähr 13 Stunden.
13 Stunden, davon schauen Sie eine Minute, eineinhalb Minuten aus dem Fenster. Meine Mandantin befand sich nach eigener Aussage um die 40 Sekunden auf dem Bahnsteig. Was glauben Sie? Wie hoch ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass von 13 Stunden Sie diese eineinhalb Minuten genau dann aus dem Fenster schauen, in der meine Mandantin am Bahnsteig steht. Erstmal, so funktioniert die Welt nicht und auch nicht Wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnungen, weil wenn man aus dem Fenster guckt, sieht man halt jemanden, dann ist die Chance, jemanden zu sehen, ist ja vorhanden. Ja, aber diese beiden Ereignisse müssen ja gleichzeitig stattfinden und Sie haben gerade gesagt, eineinhalb Minuten von dreizehn Stunden, was sind das, wie viele Prozent
sind das? Wie viele Prozent sind das?
Wie viele Prozent sind das?
Wie viel Prozent sind das?
Ich bin überhaupt nur eine Stunde zu Hause.
Wie viele Prozent sind das?
Ich bin eine Stunde zu Hause. Wie viele
Minuten haben 13 Stunden, Herr Tietze?
Das kann ich nicht rechnen,
ich habe keine Taschenrechnung auf dem Tuch.
Dann haben wir tausend. Nein, ich bin auch nur eine Stunde zu Hause. Ich bin nicht, aua! Sagen wir mal 2.000. Ich habe eine Stunde, bin ich zu Hause. Weniger als 0,1 Prozent. Also ein Sechzigstel. Weniger als 0,1 Prozent. Sagen wir 2 Prozent, wenn es hochkommt, gucke ich aus dem Fenster. Weniger als 0,1 Prozent des Tages schauen Sie aus dem Fenster. dann genau in der Zeit wollen sie meine Mandantin gesehen haben. Und sich noch daran erinnern können, dass es genau meine Mandantin war. Das ist wirklich unwahrscheinlich. Herr Tüze, 0,1 Prozent, das ist unwahrscheinlich. Sie hat schon gestanden. Ja, ich weiss. Aber das will ich noch kurz sagen. Das habe ich mir aufgeschrieben.
Jemand aus der Jury guckt schon so auf die Uhr.
Und dann habe ich tatsächlich geguckt, aber ist das natürlich eine gute Frage, oder nicht?
Wie viele Minuten?
Doch, ist doch eine gute Frage.
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage. Ich finde den Zusammenhang schwierig, gerade in dem Beispiel konkret.
Aber ja.
Und dann dachte ich mir, und dann habe ich tatsächlich mal geprüft, wie viele Minuten pro Tag guckst du aus dem fenster ich bin zuhause 24 stunden schlaf 10 stunden 14 stunden mich zuhause eine stunde dusche ich 13 stunden dachte ich so ungefähr eine stunde duscht du hatte den ganzen tag mein handy naja plus minus zwei stunden und da habe ich tatsächlich mal gemessen wie lang pro tag gucke ich so aus dem fenster normal und dann bin ich tatsächlich auf zehn Minuten gekommen. Zehn Minuten pro Tag. Da habe ich geguckt, wie viele Leute wohnen. Das Bild, was man von dir ins Internet beschiesst, das Bildst du doch auch gar nicht haben. Spargel fallen lassen, das Ding aus dem Fenster schmeißen, aus dem Fenstergucker. Zehn Minuten führte ich so ganz schön lang. Und dann dachte ich mir, wie viele Leute sind in meiner Wohnung, die Blick auf den Hof haben? Fünf Parteien. Fünf, da wohnen dann immer zwei Leute drin, zehn, zehn, hundert Minuten. Und sind von, genau, aber davon muss man ausgehen, dass da bestimmt ein paar Rentner dabei sind, die schon ein bisschen, die ihre Wohnung schon ein bisschen durch haben, die gerne mal ein bisschen länger aus Fenster gucken, und auf der anderen Seite natürlich auch Leute, die gar nicht so lange zu Hause sind wie du. Und dann, wie lange fliegt so ein Glas?
Zwei Sekunden.
Drei Sekunden, drei Sekunden.
Wohl ist aber hoch.
Wenn du rechnen mag.
Zwölfze Sekunden.
Von dreizehn Stunden, hundert Minuten.
Wie viel Prozent sind das?
Zweizig, drei, zwölf.
Und jetzt mal durch drei Sekunden ist fast nix.
Fast zwölf Millisekunden.
Also die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass jemand zur gleichen Zeit aus dem Fenster schaut, während ich den Müll werfe, ist nahezu null. Also, liebe Podcast-Ufohörer, wir halten fest, Spargel fallen lassen, ihr könnt ruhig Dinge aus dem Fenster schmeißen, Mülltrennung ist lohnt hin scheißegal. Und esst nicht zu viele Hummer, Leute. Nicht zu viel Spargel, übertreibt sich mit dem Hummer und sucht euch mal neue Freunde. Ich überlege, also warum darf man Spargel nicht, also ich finde immer dieses, ich finde mittlerweile Beilagen kritisch. Ich versuche Dinge wirklich auf ihre Essenz runterzubrechen und sie so zu konsumieren. Und diese Spargel mit Kartoffeln und Schinken. Beilagen sind noch Quatsch, Beilagen sind Sattmacher nur, weil das, was da vor allem essen willst, zu teuer ist. Genau, und oft haben die Beilagen ja auch die meisten Kalorien, gerade so dieses X mit Pommes, isst nur die Currywurst. Auch viel Kalorien, aber jetzt mal im Verhältnis, ja? Ja, das einzige Beispiel, wo das mal hat. Aber jetzt Spargel ist ein gutes Beispiel. Spargel und Russ Hollandaise. Spargel hat fast keine Karin, daneben sind schön Kartoffeln, schön Kohlenhydrate, dazu schön Hollandaise. Sos-Hollandais, Aluminade. Die einfach weg, und dann kaufst du ja halt mal so vier Gläser. Ja, zwei Euro, achtzig mal vier, was macht das denn? Jetzt hör auf, wie wir meine Wann-Erkenntnisse so reduzieren. Und dann hast du ein schönes Abendessen. Ja. Du musst ja auch nicht mehr bestellen bei dem wütenden Typen, wo man einfach so den Faustabdruck in der Paella sehen kann, weil er sich abreagiert während der Fahrt zu der Maus. Im Reis. Ein schreiendes Gesicht im Reis, weil einer in Reis schreit. Ja, genau wie diese Sachen mit den Nägeln. Oh, die sind geil, die sind wahnsinnig befriedigend. Aber haben auch ganz spezielle Haushalte. Weißt du, warum die geil sind? Weil die kalt sind. Ja. Generell mit Halb. Nee, weil sehr viel, sehr viel passiert. Ich glaube, weil der Körper ist es so ungewohnt, so viele Nerven zu beanspruchen. Auf der anderen Seite unterteile ich in Haushalte dieses Gerät haben und dieses nicht haben. Richtig. Und die es hatten. Es gibt zwei Arten, es gibt drei Arten von Menschen, Dinge, die dieses Nagelding haben. Ja. Vier Arten. Dinge, die es hatten, Leute, die es hatten, verloren haben oder es kaputt gegangen, Leute, die es dagegen entschieden haben oder die gar nicht wissen, wovon wir gerade sprechen. Und die, die es noch haben werden, aber momentan keines haben. Genau, aber auch nicht damit planen. Und die, die es aktiv kaufen wollen. Aktiv planen, sich so ein Ding zu kaufen. Die es aktiv in der Amazon-Wunschliste schon haben. Es sind ganz spezielle Haushalte, die das haben. Ja, oft auch so. Da bin ich gern zu Besuch, ich mag die Menschen nur nicht.
Ja, das ist so ein, oh, was schenken wir dem?
Es gibt auch Leute,
es gibt zwei Arten von Menschen, denen, die man
sofort weist, was man schenkt.
Und auch gerne was schenkt. Und Leuten, die einfach
kein Plan hat, was man schenkt. Leute, die einfach
keiner hat, der hat kein Bein. Ja, was schenkt man dem?
Easy. Bein.
Bein. So.
Wohingegen, jedermann, der schon zwei Beine hat, denkt sich, oh Gott, wie leid. Was ist denn dem denn? Schuhe, der hat doch schon alles. Schienbein-Schonhaar, was ist denn die so? Beinversicherung, ja, da kann man dann irgendwann, und dann so vor allem so, Kinder sind ja heutzutage so alt, die werden immer älter. Sie werden immer älter? Ich glaube wirklich, wenn ich ein Kind habe, ich glaube bis zum Alter 13 habe ich geile Geschenke, so wirklich bam, bam, bam, bam, ein Jahr nach dem anderen Geschenke. Und dann Anschluss verloren. Und dann vierzehn, ach Gott, jetzt ist Lincoln Park noch aktiv. Ja, aber dann bist du auch noch schon geschieden und dann, ähm. Ja, das stimmt. Ist auch egal. Mal so, schönen Tag mit Papa. Puh. Schön Zoo mit Papa.
Schön Besucherrechte, kommst du mal vorbei.
Papa mit der Fahne.
Zellenblock 8a, kommst du mal vorbei, erzähl dir der Papa mal was Wichtiges im Leben.
Mama, ich will nicht zu Papa, der schmeißt immer Dinge aus dem Fenster und lässt Spargel fallen.
Die ganze Wohnung stinkt nach Spargel.
Ist doch dein Geburtstagsschatz heute.
Ich bitte nicht zu Papa, alle Nachbarn hassen den.
Ich glaube auch, das ist illegal, was er macht. Wie viele Tage im Jahr hast du Geburtstag? Und... Naja. Schuldig. Leute. Schaut euch die OJ-Doku an. Die schaue ich gerade auch noch mal an. Verrückt. Richtig verrückt. Haben wir noch einen schönen Tipp zum Ende. Finde ich auch gut. Hast du auch noch einen Tipp? Du hast jetzt ganz viele Serien gesehen, du bist total mittendrin. Die kann ich eigentlich nicht empfehlen, weil die alle noch rauskommen erst. 31.05, da machst du eine große Public-Viewing-Party. Nee, was kann ich empfehlen für eine Serie? Ich weiß es nicht genau. Ich würde empfehlen. Es gibt ja zwei Parteien, die diese gerade Bock auf Game of Thrones haben. Was ist die, die keinen Bock auf Game of Thrones haben?
Was können die Leute anschauen, die jetzt diesen ganzen Hype erleben, jeden Tag und auch Spoiler, die aber einfach keinen Bock drauf haben?
Welche Serie kann man denen empfehlen, die jetzt die nächste Woche einfach mal sagen, da kann man sich richtig eingraben?
Ich gucke gerade nur Dokus und ich gucke schon wieder Two Detective Staffel 1.
Ja, aber hast du drei gesehen?
Nee, noch nicht.
Ich auch nicht, aber soll so mittel, ja, ich hab Mittel.
Ah, okay, wenn du sagst, sie soll gut werden.
Haben Sie auch noch eine Frage, die sich in, ja, ich hab Mittel. Ah, okay, wenn du sagst, sie soll gut werden. Habe ich auch noch nicht gesehen, ich weiß gerade nicht. Ich gucke gerade den Gianni Versace. Ja, ich mitten drin. Aber auch schon ein bisschen, ich schiebe schon ein bisschen länger vor mir her. Ja. Also nicht wirklich eine Empfehlung, sonst werde ich das schon ein bisschen weggebinged. Hast du Free Solo gesehen? Äh, nein, noch nicht. schau sie an, habe ich gestern Abend geguckt, also die Oscar-premierte Doku über diesen Free Climber. Wahnsinn, erstmal denkt man sich, Bergsteigen mega langweilig. Free Solo, Mountain Story. Und erstmal denkt man sich, Bergsteigen mega langweilig, aber dann denkt man sich, ah, ich habe das völlig falsch verstanden, das ist kein Bergsteiger in dem Sinne, sondern der klettert ohne Seil einfach eine steile
Bergwand hoch, super
alleine, deswegen free, solo.
Da geht es darum, dass er eben so die
berüchtigste Wand der Welt will,
er klettern und
ja. Was ist die berüchtigste
Wand der Welt? Tatsächlich,
guck mal hier,
wie heißt der hier?
Macbook. Aha, und wenn man hier so was reintippt, was kommt dann? Buchstaben. Ja, okay, und wenn man so mit die Maus so ein bisschen zittert? Maus. Wenn man so die Sachen anklickt, mal. Google. Ja, wenn man so auf verschiedene Knöpfe drückt. Tasten. Ja, wenn ich jetzt mal so gucke, oh, wie sieht das hier aus? Diese Symbole, die sehen ja gut aus. Ja, was machst du dann? Wie heißt das denn hier alles so, das drumherum? Bildschirm. Wie, das alles so? Peripherie. Nee, das ist alles so innen drin. Technik? Das Herz. Herz? So, wenn du sagst, ah, die Symbole, wie sehen die aus? So im Dock. Wie Symbole aussehen. Wie sehen die Symbole aus? Schön sehen die aus. Ja, okay. Und jetzt? Sag mal, wie die Wand heisst. Aber wie? Spotify, oder was? Nee, wie, also so wie... Hast du jemals was beschrieben in deinem Leben? Wie heißen denn so die ganzen Sachen hier, dieser ganze Text hier und diese Fenster und so? Windows. Nee.
Macintosh.
Aha!
Tosh.
Kommen wir näher.
Jetzt kommen wir schon näher.
Nee, aber jetzt so, oh, nächstes Jahr sieht es bestimmt wieder anders aus, oder?
Update.
Update Nationalpark.
Nächstes Jahr, oh, da muss ich wieder...
Yosemite.
Ah, aber, jetzt denk weiter.
High Sierra.
Ah, fast. Hä? Einen noch. Ich weiß nicht. Wie heißt denn das Betriebssystem? Linux. Okay, wir lassen. Ich weiß nicht, wie es heißt. Wir halten auf. Schau dir die Doku an. Es ist ein schöner Film. Wir hatten so viele gute Enden. So unbedrängt enden wir jetzt bei einer Minute sieben mit diesem Unwissenheit. Es ist ein schöner Film. Wir hatten so viele gute Enden. So unbedrängt enden wir jetzt bei einer Minute sieben mit diesem Unwissenheit.
Es ist ein schöner Film, schauen die an, kann man sich mal reingucken.
Wir können ja nächste Woche eine Filmmesprechung machen.
Gut, machen wir das.
Ansonsten haut rein, habt noch eine schöne Woche.
Wir sagen Tschüss.
Wir sagen Tschüss und bis bald.
Macht's gut.
Ciao.
Wie heißt es jetzt?
El Capitan.